si je te dis qu'en suisse on a décidé de
débaptiser les têtes de [ __ ] pour les
appeler tête au chaud qu est ce que tu
te crois où est passée la forme c'est de
l'intox à metz pour moi c'est de la
fausse et la faune
on va voir la suisse est en émoi en
effet au début de cette année un
fabricant de chocolat de fribourg a
décidé d'abandonner le terme tête de
[ __ ] qui désignait jusqu'à maintenant
c'est petite confiserie blanche
recouverte d'une délicieuse couche de
chocolat
motif invoqué en sait tant d'intolérance
être à la pointe de la lutte antiraciste
est devenu une nécessité incontournable
même pour les confiseurs
donc l'ancien nom est étonné que vous
voyez ici est le nouveau nom était tout
choco a changé nous avons reçu de la
part de d'élèves de la suisse romande
genève et lausanne principalement des
gentils lettre où les enfants nous ont
communiqué qu'ils avaient la peine à
croquer des ténèbres face à leurs
camarades de couleur à mener campagne
avec r kelly kim qui me battre pour mon
show saab a écrit il me critiquait le
truc comme ça moi je préfère quand ça
s'appelle la tête au choco passé moins
raciste
la direction s'est donc exécuté dans une
opération de marketing rondement menée
le résultat un tapage médiatique sans
précédent et une augmentation des ventes
évalue à 30%
mais la suisse est partagé jean ruf
journaliste a fait mine à lui défend la
tête de [ __ ] se fonde la faire et
surtout commerciale
il s'agit de vendre comme le dit
d'ailleurs villard lui-même il s'agit de
vendre
ce produit en france or la france
dispose d'une législation antiraciste et
ce team d'appellation passe mal mais
qu'en pense kofi yamgnane notre
secrétaire d'état à l'intégration
je ne suis pas d'accord qu'on débaptise
les têtes des dentelles de choco je
crois que le les mots qu'on utilise
n'ont pas n'ont pas toujours le nom pas
toujours le sens qu'on compte qu'on le
retrouve par exemple quand le pen dit
durafour crématoire
ça c'est manifestement choquant parce
qu'on sait ce qu'il pense derrière et
pour pour quelqu'un d'ordinaire dire
d'un gâteau tête de [ __ ] ou une glace
les grands suis où il un gâteau
religieuse de sanaa pas ce n'est pas
choquant en soi
vous avez dit lutte antiraciste pour eux
le débat est déjà clos manger du
chocolat noir ou blanc ça fait rosir de
plaisir
en sus
quel bonheur
rebaptisé tête choco s de l'info s de la
tête
c'est à toi de jouer salvador vous
connaissez la différence en cassant la
dordogne et en fou oui la différence
c'est que salvador dali mais pas fou je
crois un c'est tellement bête qui
s'abritent de l'intox de l'intox mais
toi vincent un show info aa on écoute
l'expert tinga
filo et bien daly le troisième coup il
aura été plantés c'était de l'info
triumph tiger commentaires avant
philippe série diriger un petit problème
je n'ai pas de commentaires à faire
parce que mon [ __ ]
tu sais de type qui m'écrit mes textes
je me suis engueulé avec lui à cause des
têtes de [ __ ] peint des têtes de choko
a tiré entre toi et moi on est pas
vraiment blanc comme neige ce type là on
applaudit l'expert
[Applaudissements]